I'm Tiffany Haddish some of you
Caucasians may recognize me from the
Oscars check out the trailer for our new
movie nobody's fool
[Music]
if I close this deal I'll be the first
black woman to be a VP in the company
hi mom hey listen it's your sister
she's gay now if you could pick her up
I'd appreciate it what time what time
honey it's Jail you get there when you
can like the song said I need a job
don't you just want me to what you want
to see me you don't know what you want
okay you could just stand right there
you think about it Charlie Charlie he is
an amazing guy she met him online a year
ago but she's never even seen him
it seems too good to be true if the man
looks too good to be true
you're being catfished we need to go and
find this son of a [ __ ] who catfished
me and we're gonna tear his ass up this
should be good
[Music]
girl I got his address we're gonna do
this tonight we don't need a saw some
plastic burner phone
I can't even that's good you need to go
ahead and let all the liquids out cuz
you don't want to leave no DNA you're
not healthy every time you try to kill
the man you're gonna squirt a little pee
I know that for sure
[Music]
mama it's Tanya cool it come on Tanya no
here mama
hello this connection is so wrecking it
hello what mama you know window I'm
sorry what we not all know cell phone
line I can't hear you baby I can't hear
[Music]
you